great news
out of utah and boise
a utah-based bank
has just pulled a sponsorship from an
upcoming boise pride festival
in backlash to a a drag kids show where
children as young as 11 were set to
perform
they say over the years zion's bank has
supported a variety of pride events
because they are an important part of
our support for lgbtq employees and
allies and are representative of our
efforts to foster an inclusive diverse
and equitable workplace and community
this support for all of our employees
uh and communities remains unchanged but
they said we're not we can't do the kids
stuff okay
we're we're really open-minded we'll
even support kind of weird sexual
parades in the streets but just leave
the kids out of it please
and the boise pride response was
we can't
we can't boise says miners have
participated in the boise pride festival
both on and off stage for many years
pride and inclusivity do not begin at
age 18. you know this story was just
going around yesterday i assume it has
to date back to pride month although who
knows actually now not only is pride
month in june prior there's another
version of pride month in october which
is the lgbtq history month so a full
sixth of the year is now dedicated to uh
eccentric sexual behaviors pretty soon
it's probably gonna be the whole year
regardless of whether this was june or
october the point remains the same
the important takeaway here is
the libs
have to push this on kids
they have to i know a lot of people who
are kind of moderate or in the center
they'll say wow this is just so crazy
the the left the sexual revolutionaries
they can get away with all the pride
stuff they want and put it in public and
probably march the the parade around
city hall they can get some of the biden
administration officials who go to
satanic leather or fetish parties and
they could probably get them to give a
keynote speech they could get away with
all of it
if they would just leave the kids out of
it why are these people so stupid why
are they so stubborn that they have to
involve the kids
but they
they have to involve the kids
because if they don't
then they are admitting that the the
events are obscene right the reason to
exclude the kids is because this is
sexually explicit obscene behavior
but if it's sexually explicit obscene
behavior
why would we have it in the public
square at all
if this is why they have to trans the
kids too there are people who are in the
middle and centrists who say come on
look if an adult wants to chop his
genitals off that's fine just don't just
don't make the kids do it but they they
have to make the kids do it
because
if they don't have the kids do it then
they are admitting that it doesn't
really make a lot of sense and it's
actually probably disordered and wrong
and you've at least gotta wait for if a
kid's gonna do something so destructive
as chopping his own genitals off he
should you shouldn't do it when he's 12
he should at least wait until he's 18 or
21 or something but but if it's
very likely disordered and destructive
and all those things
then the adult shouldn't be doing it
either
okay the the what the libs are doing
here is just taking their own premises
to their logical conclusions
men can really be women women can really
be men if a man or woman is sexually
confused they should chop off their
genitals okay if that's the premise
then absolutely you got to take it all
the way and kids should do it too
frankly kids especially should do it
because
once puberty sets in it's going to be a
lot harder to
through plastic surgery make yourself
look like the opposite sex
so that's and that's the argument that
the honest libs are making right now
and it makes sense the problem with it
is that the premise is wrong
the problem with it is that the premise
that boys can really be girls that's a
wrong premise the problem with the pride
parade here is that the premise that the
pride parade is wholesome family fun
it's just wrong it's not
it's a it's a sexual show
so you might say okay if you don't want
to ban it if you don't if you don't want
to make pass a law against these weird
sex shows fine they should be in the
back dark dingy nightclubs in back dark
dingy alleys of the neighborhoods that
the wholesome people don't go to okay
and there have been shows in those
neighborhoods forever but
there there have been weird things on
the fringes of society since time
immemorial
but you really get into trouble when you
take those things that are on the
fringes of society and put them right
into the center right into the middle of
the town square that's just absurd that
that goes way beyond tolerance that that
that takes tolerance into the realm
truly into the realm of the absurd
so the libs have to double down on all
this stuff and they're doubling down
speaking of our friends in the united
kingdom they're doubling down by turning
a beloved british children's cartoon
gay as well peppa pig i don't i've never
watched peppa pig i guess i could have
started to watch it with my children
soon but i now have no intention of
doing that peppa pig
has gone gay everything else is gay so
peppa pig has gone gay too uh critics
have apparently taken issue with peppa
pig because it glorifies the family and
by the family i mean what is now called
the traditional family i just call it
the family but it's the traditional
family you know mommy and daddy and the
kids and they live together and they
they uh are educated together and they
you know have dinners together and they
function as a family
well some critics have taken issue with
that
because on the left they want to destroy
the family because the family is a great
impediment to their cultural and
political revolutions
so in 2019 they started a petition that
demanded
that the series creators had a same-sex
couple
not just a same-sex couple by the way
same-sex couple
with
adopted or surrogate children i don't
know how they got children but
with children you know they want to
create this kind of mimicry this this
this imitation of a family with all the
kind of sexual revolution stuff built in
and so they start this petition it
obviously has nothing to do with the
plot line of the show they just demand
it because it will make them feel better
about their own sort of sexual
ideologies and delusions the petition
has garnered over 23 000 signatures
and now peppa pig has given in
they introduced a a lesbian couple and
then the little
the little
baby peppa pig says quote i live with my
mummy and my other mummy so the reaction
from this that you're going to hear from
not just the conservatives but from the
centrist people and the independent
people and the the ones who maybe even
their center left and they say why does
that why does everything have to be so
political why does everything have to be
so woke
come on why why did
can't you leave the cartoons alone this
is a very common refrain that you hear
from very reasonable people but there's
an answer to it why does everything have
to be woke
because you won't stop it
that's why
because in politics
the people who want something are always
going to win against the people who are
indifferent
that's why
because the people
who for whatever ideological or sexual
or repetitive reasons want there to be a
couple of lesbians on this kid's cartoon
they're willing to just go out there and
whine and whine and complain and beg and
shout and boycott and do whatever
and the people who don't want that very
often are not even willing to make an
argument against it
why should there not be a lesbian couple
with kids on the children's cartoon
the answer is because it's disordered
it's very disordered and two ladies
cannot create a child together and so
the only way to do that is by reordering
our adoption system or
creating all sorts of new bioethical
concerns through surrogacy and and in in
vitro fertilization and buying a man's
sperm and renting a woman's womb and all
the rest of it it's all disordered and
it's wrong and it's
morally unacceptable and that's why it
shouldn't be there
very few conservatives are willing to
say that
because they don't want to be called
phobic or bigoted or intolerant or
whatever and so they don't want to say
that all the conservatives are going to
say is come on don't you think
why does it why has it got to be so woke
it's got to be so woke because you won't
articulate the argument against it and
you won't sign any petitions and you
won't demand it and so the people who
are motivated and who are eager and who
do have a plan and a vision for society
they're the ones who are going to win
and these kind of pathetic platitudes
for neutrality or just come on let's
slow things down or hey let's leave the
kids alone it's not going to go anywhere
the everything has to be so woke
because the woke people can get away
with it
that's why hello my lords hello my
ladies go to establishedtitles.com
knowles you have to do it this is your
opportunity to earn the title of lord or
lady and gain the respect you deserve
all you need is a one square foot plot
of land in scotland established titles
can make it happen it's a project based
on an historic scottish custom where
landowners are referred to as lads or
lords and ladies in english
in your title pack you will be bestowed
with at least one square foot of
dedicated land on a private estate in
edelston scotland
plus an official certificate with a
crest your certificate features a unique
plot number with which you can see the
exact location of your land title packs
from established titles are a fun and
unique gift for any occasion there are
even couple packs because you don't want
to be a lord and then your wife isn't a
lady or vice versa so you can you can
get that for the special someone in your
life with your certificate you could
officially add the prefix of lord or
lady to your credit cards your plane
tickets even your dating profiles plus
established titles commits to preserving
the woodlands not only in scotland but
around the world they have partnerships
with global charities such as one tree
planted and trees for the future to help
with our aforestation efforts and
for every order they receive a tree is
planted
do it right now established titles told
me that the first 200 people purchasing
a title pack using my exclusive link
will receive a plot within a few walking
minutes of mine that's right so we can
be lards and ladies together depending
on how many of you want to become a lard
our lady we can build our own kingdom
established titles is running a massive
sale right now plus if you use my code
and all you get an additional 10 off go
to establishtitles.com
to get your gift now and help support
the channel i'm so glad you like that
clip now if you want to get even more
clips
would you please ring that bell
subscribe get the notifications we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]